this is a production of Cornell
University
um hi thanks to all of you for being
here
um in person and over Zoom
um I've really enjoyed the last two
years that I've been able
um Don you have been a fantastic advisor
and I'm just really appreciative of the
chance to work with you
um Janet lobach is my other thesis
Committee Member she's in human-centered
design she couldn't be here today but
um I'm also really grateful for
um her presence um they've both been
guiding lights during my time here
um and I want to thank all of you for
being here today on such a gorgeous day
last day of classes thanks for being
here inside with me
um to listen to this presentation
so um I first became interested in
environmental psychology which is what
we're going to be talking about today
um when I was a medical student
by the end of my second year of medical
school I was very stressed I had
actually developed physical symptoms of
anxiety namely heart palpitations and
migraines
um and I had already decided to do a
year-long research Fellowship through my
school
um and through a series of happy
accidents I ended up for part of that
year on the small island town in Alaska
and I liked it so much and I felt so
healthy there um that I decided to stay
for a while longer
um actually a year and a half longer
than planned
um and this is wait sorry one sec
oh
there we go
um this is what I saw every day on my
walk to work when I lived there
this is from a hike that I would go on
regularly
and this I saw on evening strolls five
minutes away from where I lived
so research predicts that on average you
and this audience just from having
looked at these photos will have
experienced an increase in your
parasympathetic nervous system activity
that's the part of your nervous system
that kicks into gear when you're doing
anything relaxing like
eating sleeping meditating that sort of
thing
um if shortly after viewing this you
experience a stressful event which I
hope won't happen I hope this is not a
stressful talk for you
um your heart rate and blood pressure
will of course go up because of the
stress but it'll return to Baseline more
quickly than if you had looked at
pictures of a city street or a building
um and then furthermore just looking at
images like these for about 40 seconds
can increase your attentive capacity for
work related tasks
so when I was in Alaska I rarely
measured my heart rate or any of these
other metrics but within a few months of
living there I remember thinking to
myself wait I haven't had a heart
palpitation in weeks
um and so I finally returned to medical
school and of course the differences
Were Striking
um one of the things that I found myself
missing most was the physical
environment of Alaska the lushness the
beauty especially in contrast to the
12-hour days I sometimes spent working
in windowless Hospital spaces
um and ever since that time I've been
interested in ways that are contemporary
Western Medical system can integrate the
natural world to benefit patients
Healthcare practitioners and the natural
world itself
um so I can't cover all of those goals
today especially how Western medicine
can start to take care of nature that's
a huge topic by the way because American
Healthcare is responsible for about nine
percent of U.S carbon emissions
um but what I do want to talk about is
how Healthcare and medical education
currently conceptualize nature as it
relates to health as well as historic
precedence for nature
um between Western medicine and the
natural world
um and then I'll talk about how current
theories research and design help us to
understand the role of nature in the
workplace and when I say nature I
realize that I'm using a term that has
vast meaning very different meaning
potentially for different people in my
line of research nature is any quote
natural element with which we interact
um so that could be a forest or a potted
plant and I realized that potted plants
can come with complex social meaning
they're more curated they're more
domesticated than something like a
forest but in theory they still carry
with them the essence of something
greater their ways of bringing the
natural world outside indoors
um and then finally we'll hone in on
these three topics of Health nature and
the workplace to talk about the results
of my thesis project which looked at the
effect of indoor plants on the wellness
of outpatient primary care workers
um
so first I think it's important to think
about how Western medicine
conceptualizes health because I think
that trickled down trickles down not
just to interactions with patients
um but also what health care looks like
including design of healthcare
facilities and uh the priorities that
are set for workers
two common models for understanding
Health are the biopsychosocial model and
the socioecological model they were
revolutionary for their time they both
came out in around the 1970s and at that
time in medicine Western medicine had
been very fixated on the biomedical
model
this idea that our health is entirely
the product of our genes and our age our
biological sex and its direct
interaction with the health care System
but we know from intuition and from
Decades of research that our health is
much more complicated our mental health
our relationships our communities
National policies and Society at large
all play a role in our well-being
um so the biopsychosocial model as far
as I have seen in practice does not
leave room for the natural world the
socioecological model if it does mention
nature it's usually in the context of
natural disasters or climate change
um so nature I would argue from these
models and from personal experience in
the field is portrayed in medicine as a
potential source of disease or injury
but not necessarily as an ally in our
health care
and when we step into contemporary
Health Care spaces I think it's safe to
say that they're stereotypically devoid
of anything that's obviously related to
the Natural World certainly
um some Pharmaceuticals from Aspirin to
a class of um chemotherapy drugs called
vinca alkaloids are derived from plants
and for anyone who wants medicine and
Horticulture or trivia aspirin from
Willow vinca alkaloids from Madagascar
Periwinkle but when you think about the
day-to-day experiences of patients or
workers in outpatient or inpatient
settings
um unless you're familiar with very
contemporary medical design I imagine
that you think of spaces like these
please let me know if you feel otherwise
of course
um so I should note that other medical
and healing Traditions acknowledge the
relationship between the natural world
and our health more than the Western
medicine does but those systems such as
ayurvedic medicine eastern and western
herbalism Etc are in my areas of
expertise
um however there is a very rich history
between nature and Western medicine the
Plant World in particular so this is a
very short list of physician botanists
physician naturalists and other medical
professionals who played important roles
in our knowledge of in Western knowledge
of the natural world
so um I included in this list some names
that I thought that both
horticulturalists and then maybe medical
professionals would realize as well
would recognize as well
um and a few of these people played
important roles in the development of um
Botanic Gardens in Europe and in the U.S
and of note a lot of botanic gardens
were um actually started with the
interest of medical professionals in
mind the interest of their education in
mind
so much of the interest in Plants during
the areas that these people lived was in
their potential as Pharmaceuticals
um but today there's a lot of research
suggesting that increased exposure to
the natural world is good for us with or
without ingesting plants
so I've looked at a number of these
studies and while they really vary in
research quality
um I think the overwhelming evidence
points to the idea that our interactions
or lack thereof with the natural world
can have an impact a sizable impact on
our well-being
this shows you the varieties of ways of
evaluating Health that have been
explored from risk of developing
depression to risk of giving birth to a
premature infant
um one compelling article that was
published within the last year found
that it was a meta-analysis
and it found that um just a very small
increase in the amount of Green Space we
live near can lead to a three percent
reduction in cardiovascular mortality
and stroke risk
um so just even small fractions can play
a big role in our health and there are
so many studies out there
um if you if any of you want me to send
you some that I've found particularly
compelling I'd be happy to do so just
let me know afterwards
um so a subset of Nature and health
research is focused on nature in the
workplace and considering that the
Environmental Protection Agency
estimates that the average American will
spend 90 percent of their life indoors
just think about that for a minute
um this is a really important line of
research I think
um and much of this research involves
potted plants
um it has found increased ability to
concentrate improve verbal task
performance
um better mood and more rapid declines
in blood pressure after stressful tasks
when potted plants are nearby
and indoor plants and workplaces have
also been associated with greater
employee satisfaction with enhanced
self-reported Quality of Life by
employees reduced Health complaints such
as fatigue and chronic pain and fewer
sick days
um there's also a subset of
environmental psychology research that
is focused on outcomes for patients who
are exposed to indoor plants and other
natural elements
uh compared to typical Healthcare
settings like what we saw earlier
in the early 1980s a study was published
that um really propelled this whole line
of research and it found that people
recovering from gallbladder surgery had
shorter hospital stays and lower use of
pain medication if their views looked
out onto Greenery compared to a brick
wall which was the other view in this in
the hospital
so this translated to on average a full
day spent less less spent in the
hospital which is actually huge in terms
of risk of hospital-acquired infections
and then of course the cost for the
hospitals themselves
um and then subsequent Studies have
found very similar results after
different surgeries if potted plants
were the natural elements someone was
exposed to not just views of greenery
and then other studies of indoor plants
on patients have tended to focus on
seniors with comorbidities such as
hypertension and dementia and found
positive results for those as well
um one of the most important theories
that underlies this research is called
biophilia I'm just curious how many of
you have heard it I realize it's a
pretty common term today yeah
um so
um for anyone who hasn't heard of it
it's a term that psychologist Eric frohm
coined in the 1970s um but it was
modified by EO Wilson to mean quote the
Affinity Affinity of human beings for
other life forms so why does nature seem
to reduce our stress levels why is it
and seem to be inherently beneficial for
our immune health for our children's
development Etc
it's because we evolved in natural
settings as this Theory we are
biologically wired to feel at home among
forests or the desert or the ocean side
and admittedly many of us don't feel at
home in those settings because of our
lived experience but our biology
suggests otherwise
um so many Industries are getting on
board with the idea of biophilia or
biophilic design specifically
um especially having indoor plants in
the workspaces so you might have heard
of the Amazon spheres
um they are three massive biodomes at
the Amazon headquarters
um in in Seattle and they were built
according to Amazon as quote a direct
link to nature for their employees they
feature over 40 000 plants most
organizations can't afford to do that
but they are opting for much smaller
scale biophilic design such as just
having a lot of plants in the workspace
or living walls
um so now that we've had a little bit of
background
um I'd like to talk about the results of
my thesis project
um and then the research the research
that I've been doing for the last two
years
um so as I mentioned there are many
studies in this field focused on office
wellness and many others focused on
patient Wellness
um but very few in fact only one that
I've heard of that looks into the way
that indoor plants can affect health
care workers themselves
um so we approach Cayuga Health which is
a large local Healthcare organization
about the idea of a pilot study to look
at the effect that potted plants placed
in offices would have on professional
Wellness namely burnout levels
um and burnout is a term that's been
around for actually a very long time but
it was formally introduced in academic
literature in the 1980s and so we now
know that anyone can experience burnout
in any field
um but it was originally studied in
fields that have
um even today some of the highest
burnout levels so that's medicine
um social services and teaching
and um today you've probably heard news
um about burnout in medicine the great
resignation of covid hit medicine
particularly hard a recent study found
that
um one in five doctors plan to leave the
field of medicine within the next two
years and two-thirds of nurses plan to
leave their current position within the
next three years so the American Medical
Association is now calling burnout an
episode
um it the dimensions formerly formally
defined in literature are emotional
exhaustion depersonalization which
um
can translate as cynicism toward
colleagues or reduced sense of caring
toward patients and then a reduced sense
of personal accomplishment or efficacy
so that often translates as a sense of
having no agency in one's organization
or reduced competence totally subjective
and self-reported but
um
our research question was can the
presence of indoor plants in medical
offices reduce the risk of burnout for
Health Care Professionals
so we approached this as a pilot study
as I said and we were trying to gain
information about how feasible a study
like this could be
um so that made having a qualitative
component particularly valuable
we randomized four primary care clinics
into treatment and control groups
treatment had two months with plants
added to their offices and control was
Baseline having no plants or maybe very
few like a plant in the office manager's
room for instance but um everyone
started with very few plants
so we administered a survey to all
workers except for the office managers
because we were working with them
directly
um at the beginning of the study before
plants were added and that consisted of
demographic data the seminal survey for
Burnout research called the maslock
burnout inventory and then the
abbreviated nature relatedness scale nr6
which asks about a person's sense of
connection to the natural world
and um after the plants replacement
offices a month later we readministered
the survey and then a month after that
we administered the third survey
um consisting of the same questions and
then the offices were allowed to do what
they wanted with the plants and many
many workers ended up taking them home
um which I thought was pretty nice
actually
um so the qualitative portion we held
after the surveys a couple months
afterwards and I held semi-structured
interviews with 13 participants we
explore people's experiences with
burnout personally their attitudes and
experiences with nature with indoor
plants and for the treatment
participants we talked about their
experiences with having plants in the
office space
um and then I analyzed the transcripts
with in Vivo software using immersion
crystallization method which is an
inductive thematic form of analysis
I was interested in Primary Care in
particular because
Primary Care clinicians tend to have
higher rates of burnout than clinicians
in other fields especially in the
outpatient setting
um so each group treatment and control
um consisted of family medicine and
internal medicine as you can see Family
Medicine offices were tended to be a
little bit smaller 13 and 16 total
workers respectively and then Internal
Medicine a little bit larger
um in a the range of total workers at
each of the office was between 13 and 25
people
so just to give you a sense of what
these clinical roles mean administrative
staff that refers to front desk workers
and medical record workers clinical
support are nurses medical assistants
and laboratory techs and providers are
nurse practitioners Physicians and
physician assistants
um and I should also note T2 one of the
treatment sites was the site of an
Internal Medicine Residency clinic so
trainees are rotating through so that's
why you see a slightly higher number of
providers because we had more providers
rotating throughout the time
we received donations of indoor plants
very generous donations from three local
nurseries and this is the list of plants
that we feature
um as you can see they tend they're
plants that are often used indoors and
tend to survive in low light conditions
and
um so yeah very grateful for the
nurseries for that
um this project was clearly not an
equivalent of the Amazon spheres we had
very limited budget we weren't even
interested in design per se we were
interested in the question do plants
themselves even not in nice pots even
not in snazzy living walls
um if they would impact the experience
of workers so we had to be very subtle
in our placement of plants because
um maybe you've seen if you've been to
an outpatient office recently they tend
to be pretty tight on space as
um and so we aim for a plant density of
quote one small plant and one large
Plant per six meters squared which is
recommended by the rural development
administration of South Korea it's the
most common recommendation that um one
finds in this line of research but
ultimately we just had to be very
flexible based on the needs of the
clinic we were working with the office
managers directly to place plants around
the office so it was really at their
discretion as you can see we place
plants in areas that were noticeable but
presumably not
um too invasive or problematic even this
gorgeous philodendron according to the
office manager that cabinet was never
used so we were able to place it there
which was nice
um
let's see so
this is a breakdown of response rate
across the three surveys I was a little
disappointed in our response rate but
considering what I know of healthcare
workers and how they tend to respond to
extra administrative duties I think
overall this was pretty solid we had a
49 response rate for survey 1 42 for
survey 2 37 for survey three and the
treatment sites were slightly better at
filling out their surveys than the
control sites were and one of the
control sites had a very dramatic
unfortunately decrease in respondents
from 52 survey 1 to 24 in survey three
um an important and unforeseen event
that happened during this was there was
huge managerial turnover
of sites during the study so treatment
site one started with a brand new
manager as you can see they have the
most consistent response rate across the
board
um treatment site too and control site 2
or no sorry control site one
um lost their managers during this
treatment site
and then control site 2 had major
managerial restructuring so I think that
contributed to the decline in a response
rate
and then we had also been working with
the office managers in our original
design was to have the same people take
the survey all three surveys we would be
able to track individual responses and
have better statistical power from that
but unfortunately there was just a lot
of turnover and we you know there was
attrition and then new new respondents
in each survey so
um it's how it goes in healthcare I
guess sometimes
um so when we look at the numbers from
the survey
I think we see interesting trends that
are subtle and that they're not
statistically significant I should note
but um they're interesting to look at
and ask what would happen if this pilot
study was able to grow into something
larger so this figure is a summary of
control versus treatment site burnout
scores as you can see control in blue
creeps upward over time in their burnout
scores and then treatment sites stays
pretty much the same over time
um we also explored
whether the treatment had different
impacts on but according to one's
professional role so I found this figure
particularly interesting since providers
over
here seem to have had a very noticeable
increase in Burnout in the control group
and decrease in Burnout in the treatment
group the other professional roles are a
little less clear although clinical
Support also definitely creeps upward in
their control group
um
so one thing that struck me about the
layout of the clinics is that
um the provider rooms were distinct unto
themselves and they had more space than
where a lot of the administrative
workers and the clinical support worked
and that's very common in most
outpatient settings actually so it meant
that we were able to put a slightly
higher density of plants in the provider
rooms
um as in we basically had unintentional
lack of equity in terms of plant
distribution and so of course it's
possible that these Trends had nothing
to do with the plants but I think it's a
really
important thing to be thinking about if
some if a study like this were to become
larger
um so we also wanted to look into nature
relatedness scores and how they might
relate to burnouts we ended up splitting
nr6 scores into high and low groups and
um
as you can see people in the high nr6
started with pretty similar burnout
levels whether they were in the
treatment group or the control group and
the control group kind of crept upward a
little bit by survey three but overall
pretty similar when we look at the low
nr6 grouping the control group
definitely creeps upward in terms of
their burnout score the treatment group
starts lower goes up a little bit and
then comes back down
so um the treatment and control low nr6
started with pretty different burnout
scores so I think there's potentially
something totally different going on
here but I do Wonder like is it possible
that um
that the presence of plants indoors
played a bigger role for low nr6
individuals than for high nr6 and
remember nr6 is referring to someone's
sense of nature connectedness so a low
nr6 might mean that a person just
doesn't see themselves as a nature
person maybe they live in a more urban
or industrialized area or maybe they
work so hard that they just don't have a
chance to get out Outdoors
so I think all of these are interesting
Trends and they really weren't greater
statistical power ideally with a larger
sample size before we can feel more
confident drawing conclusions I think
that the qualitative study allowed us to
explore more robustly issues related to
burnout workplace wellness and attitudes
toward the natural world and then for
the treatment group of course their
experiences with plants in the workplace
so
um I was really impressed that although
only one person
um mentioned the official definition of
burnout when I was asking people about
their experiences
everyone's description of their own or
their colleagues burn out could fit into
the official definition of at least one
dimension of burnout and they were
incredibly poignant and I'll um just
read one for the sake of time one
clinician said that they were currently
very burnt out and their words were I
don't care anymore and that's scary I
mean that's terrible it's like I just
let things go they aren't emergencies
but also I just let things go
um and that's really classic
depersonalization of not being able to
muster enough caring to put you know the
extra work in all of these interviews I
thought were very like visceral and
poignant about people's experiences
um
we spent a good amount of time
discussing people's experiences with uh
with the natural world so and indoor
plants so the following slides are a
couple important themes that I thought
were I wanted to share with you guys so
one was the idea of Nature and indoor
plants as inherently therapeutic and
only one person mentioned that they knew
about research and environmental
psychology but everyone had personal
experiences that seemed to refer to some
aspect of a therapeutic element to
plants so a clinician in the treatment
group said
one day there were plants everywhere and
it seemed like the best thing ever you
could see it in everybody it was great
indoor plants make you feel good
and then I had a really enjoyable
interview with um an administrative
worker in the control group who was a
home indoor Gardener themselves
and they described taking care of plants
to a benzodiazepine I thought it was
great
um it's my way of either taking a Xanax
or I go water my plants after a while
it's like you got to figure out some way
to do it on your own
and my way of doing it is my
is nice and then another clinician in
the control group said I mean sorry not
the control the treatment group said
um it was definitely something which was
calming it felt good to have those
things the plants around
hominess and familiarity was another
theme that came up I thought that was
interesting because to me it really
connects to biophilia the idea that we
naturally feel more at home in a setting
where we can relate to other organisms
so one clinician in the control group
imagined their ideal Clinic as quote
just some more of those kind of homey
touches would be fun I think that plants
would be nice to add some kind of warmth
to different areas and make it feel a
bit more Homey the word homie and
hominess came up many times I was I was
actually quite surprised about that
and then an administrator in the
treatment group said this about a
philodendron that was still in their
office we named her Aubry yep I agreed
her every morning like hey girl you're
looking good
um and to me that's classic biophilia
um the lighthearted way and then a
clinician in the treatment group
suggested that um the plants led to more
conversation with other staff it was a
great talking point they said when we'd
go to the nursing stations they would be
like this plant is doing well today or
this is not and that site unfortunately
had a mealy bug incident with the
Swedish ivy at the nurses station so um
but nonetheless it apparently promoted
Community or somewhat animated
conversation I guess
um and Community is actually something
that has been studied with respect to
Anthony
um
so a third theme that I'd like to share
is that of Escape
attention restoration theory is another
theory that underlies this research and
it says that time spent in natural
spaces
um is cognitively gentle in a way that
restores our cognitive function it
allows us to step away from stressful
settings of stressful human built
settings and it creates a positive
distraction from whatever might be going
on in our minds so some of these quotes
I think speak directly to attention
restoration Theory
um one person in the control office said
that plants were quote just something to
get you to escape for a few minutes my
workplace is sterile in the sense of
there's nothing to look at but when you
look at a plant there's always going to
be something different about that plant
and then a clinician who owned a farm
said that being out in nature doing
something outside
kind of reminds me of the bigger picture
of the world it's just comforting to
know that things are moving and growing
and living outside of the day-to-day of
work when it's really hard
and then finally an administrative
worker in the control group found being
outdoors incredibly important for their
health and also said that they wish
their colleagues would experience it
more too and they said for them the
value was just stepping away from this
you know taking technology away and just
being present and taking a breath and
just just being
um so I didn't specifically ask people
um if they thought that plants could
reduce burnout because I was trying to
avoid leading questions
and only one interviewed participant
made the direct connection
themselves between nature biophilic
design and burnout but nonetheless the
vast majority of natures I'm sorry
worker has done nature whether it was
outdoor nature or indoor plants as
beneficial for their mood for creating a
sense of hominess for offering a chance
to step away from the dullness or the
stressors of work and then the treatment
participants I think importantly
reported universally just really
enjoying having the plants around
so to wrap up I felt that our research
showed potential of indoor plants to
improve mood of workers possibly reduce
burnout symptoms
we had a lot of promising data I thought
from our qualitative interviews and we
saw intriguing if not statistically
significant Trends in the surveys and
then from a feasibility standpoint I
think that a larger version of this
would certainly be possible with just a
few modifications
um strengths of our study I thought were
a randomized design our ability to
compare Clinics of similar sizes and
Specialty and then a very robust
qualitative component
I think the weakness was in the powering
um if a future study were to occur I
would want more clinics involved ideally
and then a way to ensure follow-through
of individual participants
um and speaking of future directions
um besides a study that allows for
better statistical power
um I would hope that there would
continue to be research around the
interaction of plants with other forms
of workplace wellness and then the
impact on outpatients and then the
therapeutic relationship between
clinicians and patients and to my
knowledge I don't think that this latter
Point has been studied at all and I'd be
really interested and hope hope that
happens in the future
um
so there are a number of nature-based
Wellness programs that throughout the US
that encourage patients to spend time
with nature such as nature or RX here at
Cornell which I hope all of you have
heard of or maybe participated in
yourself
um Park RX which is a national program
that encourages people to get outside
into parks of State local or national
parks and then many prescription produce
programs there's at least one here in
Tompkins County and those really often
support local agriculture culture too
um and so I just hope that Healthcare
organizations will see more and more the
value of these types of programs for
their employees
and then this last point I'm calling for
lack of a better word ecocentrism that's
in contrast to anthropocentrisism to
anthropocentrism
um so I think the branch of
environmental psychology that I'm in
walks a fine line between acknowledging
this very powerful connection between
nature and human health and then
treating nature as an inanimate
pharmaceutical to be used solely for our
benefit without an inherent value unto
itself
so earlier I briefly mentioned other
systems for understanding Health besides
Western medicine I just really think
that health care and environmental
psychology as it relates to the Nature
Health connection
um can learn a lot from other systems
and cultures that have tended to hold
less extractive mindsets toward the
natural world
so
this is a photo from a hospital outside
of Detroit Michigan I recently got a
chance to meet the CEO of this former
CEO of this Hospital thanks to a design
class here at Cornell and I just think
it's a beautiful example of the way in
which Horticulture can fit into
contemporary health care and promote
positive environments for patients and
workers
and I should note that um
while this person was CEO the nurse
turnover rate at the hospital was three
percent and that was in contrast to the
national average at the time which was
50 and this was before covid and um so
he instituted a lot of policies that I
think promoted greater employee
satisfaction so I'm not saying it was
all this that did it but I think it's a
lovely example of what is possible in
healthcare
and so I just want to wrap up with a lot
of people to thank quickly
um but ponto's greenhouses Schaefer's
Gardens and Dylan floral they were the
people who donated the plants to us I
owe them tremendous thanks they were so
generous
um New York state flower Industries
sponsored us Cayuga medical was so easy
to work with and Ken subin was the chief
medical officer at the time and this
would not have happened without him and
then I have so many faculty members to
thank
um Don and Janet particularly as I said
you've been wonderful to work with and
then
um others too who I think have really
welcomed me supported me and inspired me
at different lengths of my time here at
Cornell thank you and then um many
family and friends but especially my
parents who gave me the last name of
green I'm very grateful as
for that and then my Wonder
who's been with me on this whole length
of the time here and if you have any
questions that percolate later or you
don't have a chance to ask them please
please email me because I'd love to talk
and so
yeah
um if anyone has any questions please
feel free to ask yeah
so my wife works at the Keuka medical I
get to hear about those three aspects of
burnout every night oh wow
all right so where'd you get that
we're good for the patients
so we've got to get rid of them a cold
bond there I remember I was shocked I
told her so you got to find out the
source of that because that's really not
true yeah and so as a turnout of the
line the issue was
they couldn't find anyone to take care
of the plants or the result was a burden
to take care of them so it seems to me
that a hospital a lot of hire somebody
whose job it is to populate the rooms
and plans to take care of them take that
burden off of do whatever custodian or a
nurse or you know whatever because if
it's true that it reduces patients they
like every day in the hospital it was
ten thousand dollars saving it right and
you know the recovery rates and all that
seems like it's really worth the
investment so I wish we could have a
pilot where we actually looked at it
somebody for like three months or that
was their job to take care of the
classroom hospitals have records of all
this if you can have controls you can
compare the patient outcomes yeah in
those situations I was really surprised
at the misinformation about plants and
other somehow it's bad for people and
then also that nobody wants to take care
of them and that's a barrier to adopting
these things you're talking about yeah
thank you for sharing that that's really
interesting
sure and I love
your future study
um yeah that um I think that I have
encountered in other settings that
belief that plants are somehow dirty
because they have
soil in them are actually often soilless
substrate right in them and that they're
somehow not not healthy but I think
you're right that the the big barrier is
that people feel so stressed and they
feel like it's going to be um add an
added burden to them I actually didn't
share a quote but there was a clinician
who really loved the plants in the
treatment offices and um but said that
when they first arrived it was the
immediate impact was great and then
suddenly this fear set in and they they
thought oh my gosh who's gonna take care
of these plants and they said you know I
know that our organization had been
talking about oh let's address physician
wellness and then this person was like
great so throw a bunch of plants at us
and expect us to take care of them and
like add to our workloads
um then they found out that someone else
was taking care of them it was fine but
um yeah I think that the biggest barrier
probably is stress levels of workers
even though I'm sorry one point even
though
um there is definitely evidence that
direct interaction with indoor plants
rather than just having them around
around you but actually repotting them
or watering them or nurturing them in
some way has more positive effects on on
us than than just having one nearby so
well to Marvin's point I know that it's
also a traditional and totally erroneous
belief that plants deprive us of oxygen
so that when you're in a closed room we
have less oxygen of course that's the
opposite of what's true that's a good
point I and found this wonderful book
from 1887 published by an MD PhD who is
a big fan of house plants or indoor
plants and spends half of the book
trying to disprove that theory actually
because it was around in his era and it
seems to still carry true today although
I think a lot of people do see plants as
being beneficial for the air quality and
there's I think mixed data about that I
I would want to research that a little
bit more but yeah
so so
be the geek
I understand what your situation was
there just wasn't hundreds of people to
do this with right so
um how how did it how did it go with the
um
uh uh the trial said she at such a low
number and all of a sudden here's all
these plants and then some people didn't
get them how did you catch that wait say
that say that one more time so some
people had the plants and some people
did not right
yeah so
so how did that
go
in other words in
uh surveys and things how do they not
know what's going on oh that's a great
question yeah we couldn't fully blind
this
um and that's I mean I suspect that
plenty of people knew that there was
something you know they get the survey
about wellness and then
five days later they get a bunch of
plants in the office you know and so we
were thinking about that and then just
in most of these studies
um there's there's no way to officially
blind people from the treatment because
you're supposed to see it that's part of
the the thing and so
um yeah but in terms of trying to keep
the full nature of the study Under Wraps
I think we did pretty well we've asked
the office managers to share it as
little as possible when I interviewed
people it seemed that most people
um didn't have a truly robust
understanding of what our exact research
question was or anything so I think I
think we managed to keep it under wraps
and I always went in after hours so
every now and then I would interact with
a few employees but for the most part
especially at one office I never
interacted with employees just with
maintenance who came in so it was trying
to stay as stealth as possible so yeah
yeah does anyone have any other
questions or
there could be this is a little bit but
there could be a before and after
experiment in Bradfield
[Music]
somebody could actually come up with any
money to study the occupants of
Bradfield and then put the windows in
it's it's a beautiful experiment I love
it yeah
let's do it
you know there was a seminal study done
a number of years ago bill with
residents of a low-income housing
project in St Louis and when people
applied to live there they were randomly
assigned to an apartment either ones
that had a view of greenery tree shrunks
turf or views of parking lots and they
found remarkable
significant differences between the two
groups lowered prime or socialization
Etc yeah oh yeah the the one of the
early pictures of I presumed that was a
European picture of which one went back
well the two guys working in the office
oh
yeah that's a great question I need to
go back to the website where I got that
yeah
spent a lot of time in Fargo and the
difference in window size
is is between them and the US it's
unreal yeah and so those common offices
like that and it's not even cubicles
it's not little wool cubicles it's a
it's a much more open thing so even if
you're on the other side of the room you
still see the outside you still have
real sunlight and you can still see the
plants interesting yeah yeah we have a
lot to learn I think from biophilic
design from other parts of the world for
sure yeah
um I think you had a question or we have
like one more minute as you mentioned
the perception that things are kind of
dirty
um that as a potential like
uh this is something that the people get
hung up on are there steps that you have
to take when you're putting plants and
these medical settings to ensure that
they like meet certain standards of
cleanliness or can you really just like
put them anywhere you want and they're
considered to be pretty much okay yeah
we were really lucky because of Ken
subin being the chief medical officer
once you get
um the approval from someone that high
up you can you can do a lot actually
um and so
um but in other experiences that I've
had prior to coming here I um you know
worked for a residency clinic and was
trying to do a lot with
um uh Community Gardens and Gardens on
site and I think definitely having the
buy-in from maintenance as well as upper
level Administration is essential but
there aren't any
regulations around Health uh house
plants or anything Inside by you know
um some governing body so I think we're
out of time but again like please please
email me if you have any other
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu